اذا احتجاجات ايران تقضي على الجهه التي
اشعلت شراره الاحتجاجات بعد اتهامها
بالتسبب في وفاه الشاب مساء اميلي نتحدث
هنا عن شرطه الاخلاق التي اعلن امس المدعي
العام حلها بعد اكثر من شهرين ونصف من بدء
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه بيانا لدعاء العام
اضافه ان الغاء شرطه الاداب او ما تعرفوا
بدوريات الاخلاق ياتي من قبل الجهه التي
اسستها في الماضي مع فك ارتباطها بالقضاء
اعلان المدعي العام محمد جعفر منتظري عن
الغاء دوريات الاخلاق اثار جدلا في ايران
حول ما اذا كانت الحكومه جاد في تطبيق هذا
القرار ام انه مجرد تكتيك لتهدئه الشارع
الذي باتى يطالب بتغيير النظام برمته
تصريحات منتظري في ندوه بتهران ركزت على
انه رغم الغاء هذه الدوري الا ان الجهات
القضائيه ستستمر بمراقبه سلوك المجتمع
خاصه فيما يتعلق بالحجاب قبل ذلك اعلن
المدعي العام يوم الخميس ان البرلمان وما
يسمى بالمجلس الاعلى
لثوره الثقافيه سيبديان رايهما خلال
اسبوعين في قضيه الحجاب الاجباري في
البلاد
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
دي السعوديه
وعلى راسها دوريات المسيج والشرطه والامن
الداخلي وحتى اشرطه المرور في الوقت ذاته
يعتبر الكثير من الناشطين انه مجرد
الاعلان عن قرار الالغاء وحتى لو كان
شكليا
اجازا للمتظاهرين سيدفع النظام نحو تقديم
مزيدا من التناسلات كما انه سيكل دافع عن
اكبر الاستمرار الاحتجاجات بعد الناشطين
اعتبر وان القرار الاخير يهدف ايضا لتخفيف
الضغوط الدوليه عن النظام مع تزايد
العقوبات من العقوبات الغربيه بسبب قتل
المتظاهرين واستمرار القمه الحكومه
البريطانيه فرضت الاسبوع الماضي عقوبات
على شرطه الاخلاق والرئيس العام لها اضافه
لقائدها
الاتحاد الاوروبي ايضا عناصره من دوريات
شرطه الاخلاق والمسؤول عن اعتقال مساء
اميني ومسؤولين اخريننا ايضا ادرجت
الولايات المتحده وكندا شرطه الاخلاق
الايرانيه على قائمه العقوبات بعد
احتجاجات واسعه النطاق على مستوى البلاد
العقوبات وصلت ايضا لشركه تيتاندي الصينيه
التي وفرت اجهزه التعرف على الوجه لصالح
الحكومه الايرانيه بعد ما اعلن موسى غضنفر
ابادي رئيس اللجنه القانونيه والقضائيه في
البرمانه عن استخدام تقنيه التعرف على
الوجوه كبديلنا لدوريات شرطه الاخلاق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]